hi guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry um you
know I just realized what did you just
realize Star Wars is owned by Disney
Disney Owens Marvel and now that Disney
owns Marvel I am wearing a Star Wars
shirt for Marvel's greatest heroes
Batman and Superman yeah
totally that's the right combination of
label and characters yeah Batman V
Superman dawn of Justice marble in the
next movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe if I'm not mistaken a is 5 face
5 they're skipping ahead that's cool
I know Suicide Squad they're gonna bring
in villains so that way they can put
them in the next Avengers Marvel yeah
you know like I'm a much like Tarantino
I like to get my facts right guys watch
it girl the gloves come on
Tarantino all right are we gonna watch
the TV spot number one and number two
and then we're gonna see if there's any
new thoughts that can be sparked from
watching these two TV spots if we can
incite any more hatred yeah bye
you know expressing an honest opinion
let me give you a summary of what I felt
with the last trailer no boy here we go
I know it's called dawn of Justice at
the end it's supposed to set up a
Justice League however we're already
gonna get it Justice League movie I
would like it if the promotion and the
movie itself primarily focused on Batman
V Superman this movie yeah the next
movie yeah I know it's good I don't I
know it's not a spoiler it's called dawn
of Justice that they're gonna be friends
in the end Marvel I hear Iron Man might
appear in this totally he's gonna first
fan
the card converts so nice
[ __ ] huh buddy fly away answer the
[ __ ] question Superman
tell me do you believe later you like
one away as if he was scared oh well
he's just laying odds are gonna be right
now oh yeah he's like [ __ ] you dude do I
bleed nah I can do this though honestly
this TV spot in a lot of ways is kind of
what I wanted to take away from the
second trailer this is just Batman
Superman yeah it's not it's not showing
us the fight but it's teasing the fight
yeah yeah it's teasing the conflict
between Batman and Superman yeah which
is what we wanted to see I thought we're
really seeing a tired Ben Affleck in
this he's hired Batman
even under the masking light you look
pretty tired he's kind of just gloomy
and just like I'm sick of the world yeah
I want to see more of this perform like
I am eager to see the movie because I
want to see this performance as a whole
just because like the little snippets we
get of him as Batman he does look kind
of tired but we only ever get like four
words well I might know what his a wait
wait let's not pop ahead yet oh sure
there's more we got a second TV spot to
watch man maybe what we desire might be
in this TV spot okay why No
you know I really don't see how they can
link guardians of the galaxy in this
world though I think it works perfectly
trees exist and Gotham
I feel like star-lord can take down
Superman that should be the next one
that they do in the Canon
star-lord versus Superman our Lord
versus Superman dawn of the Guardians
miss away Clark Kent Daily Planet civil
liberties are being trampled on in your
city the bat vigilante thinks he's above
the law don't believe everything you
hear
boys Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I love
it I love bringing people together like
sand is a pledge oh wow it is a good
grip you should not pick a fight with
this person
wait I think you're that one line
correctly boy wise well I know why but
like Shh are you ready to shut your
[ __ ] mouth yes sorry I listened to
the Christian Bale ran in the Mel Gibson
tapes against it
civil liberties are being trampled on
your city the bat vigilante you think
seed above the law don't believe
everything you hear
why is he see yeah that's a dope line
yeah and also it's a toe blood bad man
to say that's Superman I'm gonna cool
man I get like we need to see the movie
to know what the context of this scene
it
Superman is basically going you're
Batman and this is [ __ ] up and then
he's going I'm Batman
oh yeah you're [ __ ] Superman you
destroyed metropolis it's like yeah
that's basically the point of that holy
Sh
it seems like from from from this
limited amount of information I gotta
say though like re watching this because
I know they showed like pretty much the
scene and the other trailer they just
focus on the scene and looking at the
expressions of Ben Affleck and the
delivery yeah I feel like he's got
something like you need to bring yeah I
really do like at first I was like I'm
not seeing exactly Ben Affleck as Batman
but little not to him and stuff and and
that wine delivery don't believe
everything you hear son something like
that yeah that's the way he said it was
impactful like you made me want to
rewind it just to see that it seems like
he made an actual choice instead of just
saying the line like you get a sense for
why he said yeah what he's feeling like
he's actually made a choice as a
performer with that line and the
demeanor in him just seems like a
depressed dark dude who has a lot of
anger hidden in him oh oh maybe but I
mean in this scene I get a more vital
sense in this scene cuz he's challenging
him he's pushing back at Clark well he
can't fully unleash it he's under the
guise of the Bruce Wayne persona right
now yeah I know it's something it's
simmering just below the surface but I
don't get depressed
out of this moment I get oh yeah you
want to come at me with this I'm talking
about everything I've seen so far not
the specific singing I'm talking about
with everything I've seen this is kind
of what I gathered from the performance
of Ben Affleck just from the trailers
that this guy is in a really dark place
he's he seems really serious same time
there's like the mysterious charmed I
don't know this secret I mean I'm
getting all this stuff from watching him
and you know what I remember reading an
article from Hollywood Reporter where
they said Ben athlete got a standing
ovation because of how great he was in
the movie and I'm like looking at his
performance as Batman other scenes and
I'm like this guy does seem like a much
more haunted Batman maybe I mean he
certainly seems like a more serious like
he's like this is his life he's very
focused on his work is what I get from
him like I don't know they're like he
might be depressed and haunted I haven't
gotten that as much in a big way from
what well I have cuz I know human beings
unlike you yeah totally and I don't they
have the [ __ ] set man I feel like
every actor who plays Batman has to
prove himself twice it's like you gotta
prove you can do Bruce Wayne you gotta
prove you can do Batman you have to
bring two choices that relate to each
other for both it's like you need to
make a choice as to how you'll play
Bruce Wayne how you'll play Batman and
find a way to link them so they feel
like the same guy somewhere like right
now I see him and I like what he's doing
is Bruce Wayne and I feel like I at
least get nuggets of it I'm not quite
sure what he's doing is Batman and
that's what I would into I feel like I
don't know I feel like I got a define
version of him so far these moments that
we've seen of him as Batman or like
tough guy but like like always in the
middle of this [ __ ] but like the other
Batman moments where he's like you know
in between crime areas or talking to
Alfred or dealing with logistic not the
apex Batman moments but like the the
Batman I feel the emotion in his eyes in
this I've seen a lot of Ben Affleck
performances and I I feel like this is
he's totally channeling a new person in
this yeah I'm not saying he's not I'm
just saying like I get a I'm getting an
inkling for what he's for what makes his
Bruce Wayne distinct I get less of an
inkling from these trailers from the
scenes these trailers have shown us for
what his bat
we'll be which is why I'm interested to
see the movie so I can really get what
he's doing as Batman because these
trailers can ride on just like oh cool
Batman like you know when I watched the
trailers and especially with this scene
I'm looking at Ben Affleck and and I'm
remembering because I've seen all the
trailers multiple times and I'm looking
at how a few times where he is Batman
we're in Batman and the trailers and
what do you do to get a seam speak like
in the previous TV spot what I'm liking
from seeing is that when you see Bruce
Wayne you also see Batman when I saw
Christian man Christian Bale had the
intentional choice which worked for the
Dark Knight trilogy of when he's Bruce
Wayne he's totally different as it's an
act that he's a total persona it's not
way no one would suspect he's Batman
yeah when he's Bruce Wayne he's almost a
stereotype yeah and that's what I like
about what I'm saying Ben Affleck's
Bruce Wayne he doesn't look like he's
going out there to be mr. charming and
it's like he's yeah he seems rather much
more calm and his demeanor well yeah he
seems like a serious man of his stature
like yeah he seems like an affluent
member of the upper crust society who
you know goes to whatever galas these
are I mean he might still be a
millionaire playboy to some degree maybe
but yeah he does seem like a more
focused guy you know like a more
straight ahead like he you know it's
probably steadfast to what he believes
in probably an active member of society
and again this is it's not a complaint
either I'm a the Bruce Wayne versus
Batman for me is not a complaint I just
get a better sense for Bruce in these
trailers and Batman I'm still like I'm
curious as to what that character is
you're repeating yourself well no but I
but you argued with me like I was
complaining and I want to clarify every
what I say you were complaining when you
assumed you assumed instead of just
clear everything mean a Cuban folks
outside it is not a complaint okay I get
a better sense for Bruce than Batman
right now which is more Drive to see the
movie so that I can get what he's going
yeah yeah because like whenever I see
Batman these chairs I'm like oh cool
it's Batman I want to know what Ben's
back
man is like although even though you're
bitching and complaining a lot visiting
your command just getting frustrated and
annoyed that's what these trailers are
for like give you hints and make you
wonder what's going to happen yeah yeah
yeah whatever Ben Affleck though I like
Ben Affleck that's what I love about the
marketing of this particular aspect is
it's getting you hooked into how is he
going to do Bruce Wayne well yeah it's
basically proving to you that Ben
Affleck is probably a good choice yeah
like most of the time like with Batman
it's usually like that man yeah only
Batman I'm like I want to see his
portrayal of Bruce Wayne really bad I
mean I do want to see his Batman but I'm
finding myself incredibly intrigued to
see how he does Bruce Wayne well because
the Bruce Wayne performance is the more
impressive performance because we see
his face we know who he is and we don't
get like with Christian Bale like he
wasn't a household name when he became
Bruce Wayne for Batman Begins that
helped make him a household name and
whereas this is like by now everybody
knows Ben Affleck and the rises and
falls of his career so for him to play
Bruce Wayne there's more to prove and so
I think it's it's neat that they're
doing it this way because he seems like
he's proving it like yeah like in these
I'm like well I'm kind of not like I'm
aware it's Ben Affleck but I'm not
distracted that it's been out when I
really could be I mean he might be the
coolest one yeah he could be great like
I think he's I'm excited to see what he
does with this I'm not like this I'm
excited to see what he does I'm excited
to see what what Jesse Eisenberg does
and when when Ben Affleck you know as
Batman works with Paul Rudd as an ad man
because he's if I can remember correctly
from what I read that man is supposed to
be the next villain in ant-man
yeah before I remember is Hellboy cuz I
remember out of Batman's
you know rogue of villains I believe
ant-man was in there too so they're like
enemies yeah yeah mmm Batman an ant-man
or enemies but then they have to team up
to fight Hellboy before they go meet
Archie common no dude Hellboy is from DC
oh sorry if you want to know what we
think about jesse eisenberg we've talked
about it in the other video
I'm the only person who is really
excited about it
you mean you don't like his Riddler
performance listen guys if you're new to
the Chanel subscribe today become a
reject please please makes me look
better when there's more numbers makes
reasons to GRE is a playlist that
features this guy's [ __ ] face and
dank ass dubs is a playlist that
features his [ __ ] voice as a podcast
hosted by this other guy with a deeper
voice named Aaron yeah he does have a
nice Barrett he does have a nice
baritone as the Houma phones all the
times when you go through a cyclone
james c kkona i never know what to say
when it comes to these singles yeah
Jerry really sorry I'm gonna rub me I
got nothing to rub in it I never know
what to say when it comes to these
things so just give me a shout out for
the [ __ ] of it oh wow you are demanding
James King and gonna did you know kid
gonna I think it's a Gonia it's a sex
position oh it's no all right rather
than telling you what it is like I
normally do uh we're gonna sort of
demonstrate it for you no dude you're
[ __ ] her from behind
and then you pick her up you start
eating her out she pisses on your face
you get grossed out and then you vomit
for the [ __ ] of it that's what you get
for being rude asking for a shout-out
that's your last name that's your family
name whatever Jerry I'm quitting
cigarettes I'm taking out my this video
is already over 15 minutes you were
annoying there's like a cockroach on the
ceiling